the argument that I think taking on
cartoons because last point about when
countries become independent I think
this is something that Russian
politicians has all been complaining
about saying that all this is the end of
the world was a block mentality those
people hate us and they're actually
creating more problems in a relationship
with Europe because they became
independent and they're trying to play
their own political games and gaming
installation I think that them a lot of
that will depend on whether they will be
actually shale gas development in the
foreseeable future in those countries
that you mentioned because I think that
Russians really have the capacity to act
quite quickly and as I said earlier
there is a lot of pressure now
particularly from a company such as
novitec but also from the Russian oil
can all companies particularly Rosneft
to which is moving into gas business
very actively very actively and the
could potentially displays Gazprom to a
certain degree within Russia and also
externally so I don't know I think that
it's often difficult to make predictions
your question is it related to 10 years
20 years 30 years 40 years but when we
look at this another important aspect to
remember about all these forecasts what
we're talking about if you look at the
latest they're talking about 20 35 20-40
so by looking about you know 20 30 years
ahead look at what we're now in year
nineteen twenty twenty thirty years
ahead what has happened in the world so
I think this is this is an important
point that the world is changing at a
very fast pace and I think that a lot of
this a lot of this forecasts and
predictions adjust just a guide for us
to to
no base our decisions